la bande bonjour comment ça va ça va
bien vous savez bien versé jarre est un
petit bout pour beaucoup aux côtés de
dos
côté de djoko bienvenue à montréal et si
la rivalité montréal québec vous tous ce
que ça a été une réalité dans votre
mandat comment vous allez gérer ça au
début c'est exister parce que bon ça
dépend du propos d'éthique des élus
québec et des élus de montréal alors je
sais je suis de mettre mon pas aussi
pour faire à équilibrer la balance mais
au total ça s'est bien passé je vous
dirai pas ce que
la nature du vote puis à de l'important
est parti d'un jardin dans chaque région
alors québec t'habiller traiter et à
tous les citoyens qui est ce que c'est
encore deux planètes selon vous mais le
québec au total ce que j'appelle le
reste du québec et montréal ya une très
grande différence un fossé un gap qui
s'élargit je pense d'année en année
c'est pas de la faute de personne mais
ça existe ça existe démographiquement et
sociologiquement mais bon pour y penser
un jour et ça vous fait peur oui en
terme de cohésion sociale ça peut être
compliqué 28 m'en faut pauvre pas trop
s'énerver avec ça mais y'en a marre pas
moins que le québec régional le québec
de l'est du québec ne reconnaît plus
montréal mais encore là je vous rappelle
que personne en raison là bas c'est
juste une différence de plus en plus
nette j'ai deux jeunes craintes de ceux
qui sont différents aussi se dire oui
les gens toujours par deux les connu un
en même temps les québécois francophones
on est une minorité historique alors on
est on a des stigmates qui lui colle à
la peau depuis très longtemps et c'est
bien sûr que quand on se demande si
notre vote utile vote francophone
éventuellement
démographiquement votre plaisir encore
de la balance bah c'est inquiétant alors
ceci dit il ya rien à faire sinon que
d'apprendre à vivre ensemble parce que
tout ça est inédite on n'en sort pas le
québec va avoir besoin d'immigration
c'est il ya même pas de question se pose
est alors le prochain pas faire c'est
vraiment de que nos leaders apprennent
et s'investissent dans la promotion de
l'autre et de la différence mais vous
moi je me suis vous après le drame de la
mosquée québec
parce que je fais un parallèle en
politicien en france qui m'ont monsieur
zemmour aurait beau jouet pour lui
l'islam est incompatible avec la france
vous avez été vous avez votre réponse a
bien montré que des musulmans qui
s'intègrent à québec c'est totalement
possible c'est ça qui est telle qu à
écouter les les musulmans les maghrébins
la deuxième
commande est la deuxième communauté
culturelle à québec ce sont les
maghrébins et ça va très bien il passe
ou si c'est juste que comme disait c'est
faire bien non d'un site la peur de
l'inconnu et c'est une minorité une
chance d'une minorité qui est s'inquiète
d'un autre minorité alors on est entre
eux deux et les quelque chose de
psychologique d'analysé parce que nous
on a envie une et sécurité culturelle et
même la france de vie peau de sécurité
culturelle elle commence avec une
insécurité culturel et j'en parlais que
juppé pas plus tard qu'hier alors quand
tu étais secure culturellement pas
évidente il est évident que tu
t'inquiètes des autres minorités qui
vient s'installer chez vous alors il ya
comme à une grosse valise de maquereaux
psychologique à faire là dessus mais ça
prend des leaders allumés qui explique
il faut surtout expliquer qu'on peut pas
passer à côté de pensée qui a moins
d'immigration au québec c'est ça le
v12 passé qu'elle a fait des gains
politiques en disant on va aux veaux
mois cueillie d'immigrants ça ne se peut
pas monsieur legault répète ça oui il
l'a fait politiquement même moment donné
il va il va danser prise de les voir
parce que l'économie ne pourra pas
résister et là on vit des choses
dramatiques bon ça fait rire c'est comme
si on remarquerait tout à coup qui
manque de main d'oeuvre je pense que
fortin puis à forte elle expliqué peu
près y avait 25 les courbes
démographiques était évident pour tout
le monde sauf que comme les politiciens
comment dire gouverne pour le lendemain
ils sont peu préoccupés bon ça existe
avec qui vous avez eu plus de facilité à
travailler le codeur madame 3e moi
j'aime beaucoup veulent des rites c'est
une bonne personne je pense qu'elle fait
les choses pour les bonnes raisons elle
l' usure aussi mais je peux je faisais
mon ami denis j'ai pas une nouvelle
depuis longtemps alors je peux pas vous
en parler le tramway vous avez dit venez
dire les politiciens des fouaces trop à
courte vue est-ce que ça a été dur dit
moi tout est ce que c'était dur de
convaincre québec de faire ce projet la
hausse était c'était peiné comme c'est
pas possible
j'ai 13 ans de ma vie mon investi la
date du 13 mai vie c'est mon troisième
projet et à chaque fois les projets vont
tomber pour des raisons de comment dire
de guerre politique à faire jamais les
politiciens provinciaux qui ont pris
d'édition là dessus se sont demandés si
fondamentalement c'était nécessaire ils
sont juste demander si oui ou non il est
la gagner ou perdre des votes c'est
dégueulasse c'est franchement
dégueulasse vous le croyez vraiment à
john pas je le pense à vomir tout ça est
mais bon on y est arrivé mais c'est
extrêmement décevant parce que ses
soutiens on vit sur la même planète que
tu ne montes tout le monde sait qu'on a
besoin de transport collectif donc vous
vise évidemment la quête et les libéraux
ou la caq particulièrement au cem est
arrivé pendant mes 14 ans alors tout le
monde et tout le monde tu ne payes
également
cela m'en parlez moi faites moi rêver
parlez-moi de sport parce que vous
l'achetez at on besoin d'avoir ce que
vous croyez qu'un jour
genève en avril
mais c'est donc parce que tout le monde
a faim qu'on construise un amphithéâtre
et on n'a pas besoin drac et là on a
besoin de ça on a besoin d'un
amphithéâtre pour les spectacles pour
être une ville nordique
d'envergure et tout à coup depuis que
napster jobs n'y a pas de match doit
commettre ma charge et bella entendons
nous moi je les conçois mais j'espère
qu'on a on aura un club de hockey mais
je n'ai pas fait nécessairement pour ça
oui un peu certains mais pas juste pour
ça c'est au vieux colisée il y avait
plus de spectacles qui venait là on
n'était pas techniquement capable
d'accueillir des gros des donc ça c'est
là dans la colonne de vos réussites
bosnie
puis les olympiques jo 2002 on a fait
les olympiques un jour où le ski chance
et développées de l'est des grandes
compétitions la naude là à ce que québec
il ya encore de la place pour des plus
grandes familles si on les avait voulu
on les aurait eus les agripper dites
vous bien sûr je ne veux plus j'aurais
été capable d avoir savez les sens
venant des pays au pont de neige où ils
doivent créer de l'adage
artificiellement et l'on fait là alors
si j'avais voulu on les aurait eu eux
mêmes on est aussi dit fier non pour ça
ça n'a plus de bon sens c'est trop cher
c'est d'abord trop cher pour deux
semaines
d'autre part c'est un milieu qui est
tordu ans était vraiment heureux alors
nous ont saisis notre guerre nous c'est
quel est le meilleur et bien pas pour le
meilleur est tombée alors on va chercher
des compétitions sportives de niveau
international comme le vélo ski de fond
et on sait qu'on en a pour notre argent
un jeu la bande à un maire est ce que ça
du pouvoir face à québec ça n'est pas
comme un esclave up et cités il était
venu de la population c'est assez simple
c'est qu'a t il après des succès plus ou
moins c'est à 300 des 10% dans les airs
ôta gt cup c'est à 42 et écouter les
programmes philosophie avec ce qu'est ce
qui vous choque pas dans le monde
municipal quand vous regardez dans cinq
dix ans layette parce qu'un écueil à ce
que les choses que vous aimez pas le
plus gros problème au pays de sécurité
dans les grandes villes canadiennes
c'est la santé mentale et les
grands-mères les maires des grandes
villes on leur répétait ce n'est plus et
plus le crime organisé c'est les
problèmes de santé mentale dans la cité
première affaire deuxième affaire c'est
ce sont les sources d'eau ce sont la
vulnérabilité des sources dont on n'a
pas idée
comment éventuellement on va avoir des
problèmes d'accès à des sources d'eau
potable et on est au québec et on est
heureux on est au québec on avait un
reportage sur saint lin laurentides
c'est épouvantable
il faut venir des camions et un trou de
développement sont le fait du québec on
fournit de l'eau à une municipalité de
la rive-sud de québec les maires font du
développement mais il comprend qu'il ya
une espèce de mur fiscale éventuellement
ils pensent qu'ils m'envoient des taxes
mais oublient qu'ils doivent à bord et
investir à long terme
il frappe le mur à chaque fois mais que
voulez vous c'est l'espèce de
vision qu'on voit additionner les taxes
mais les sources d'où la vulnérabilité
des sources d'eau québec le mois je vous
dirais que ça va devenir sérieux très
bientôt sur la bande de quoi vous êtes
le plus fier
ben écoute et aux jeunes de rentrer à
nice jean sauvanet alors si c'est ça
bravo pour moi c'est suffisant la veste
vous voulez c'est d'exister on arme et
s'est déjà tracé
on n'a pas eu de flag à cela dans l
hôtel de ville on a peur on était un
esprit mais juste la bombe fois là vous
allez pas nous bercer
j'aimerais tellement ce devenir fédérer
je sais pas j'ai besoin de repos je
m'accorde le véhicule ok mais la
politique c'est une page à l'annoncé
terminé
terminé fini fini c'est la bombe un bon
séjour à montréal merci à fait plaisir
de voir ça merci beaucoup merci